shocking allegations about the Recording
Academy are threatening to overshadow
music's biggest night the Grammy Awards
which air here on CBS Sunday night the
group suspended CEO Deborah Dugan says
the Grammy nomination system is rigged
in response the Academy says quote
voting members make their choices based
solely on the artistic excellence and
technical merits of eligible recordings
we're joined by Randy Lewis a staff
writer for the LA Times who is tracking
the fallout Randy just my limited
experience here everybody guys talk to
in the music business is talking about
this yeah what's your what's your sense
of what's going on it's like a nuclear
device has been detonated in the middle
of Grammy Week it's really unbelievable
I've been covering the Grammys for the
LA time since Michael Jackson wanted for
thriller and I've never seen anything
like this and everybody is talking about
it and most people just don't know how
to respond at this point there's lots of
charges flying back and forth and
responses and replies for responses and
you know it's gonna take a long time for
it all to shake out but but it's really
extraordinary what's what's being said
the Academy the Academy says every
economy says all of these charges are
false you believe them
well what what complicates this is that
the Academy created a task force in 2018
after there was a big blow up when the
president said that women needed to step
up to achieve parity because it's been
so male-dominated and this task force
made 18 recommendations and found
systemic gender and racial biases that
were working against so a lot of people
in the music business and so it feeds
into many of the accusations that the
ousted president Deborah Dugan has made
Randy what are you hearing from the
artists themselves because I'm very
curious about what that red carpet is
going to be like on Sunday we are too
artists the artists I talk to people are
first of all they're nervous about going
on the record to say anything they're
being very cautious about it because you
know a Grammy can really change a career
and a musician's life and they're
they're nervous they don't know what to
think and they're just wondering what's
going on yeah indeed Randy Lewis for us
Randy Lewis from the LA Times Randy
thank you very much